welcome back we're in this camera hey
we're back on the Samsung stage and I'm
joined by Dan hey executive producer of
far cry 4 this is the demo of the day
and I've been most excited about that
it's a pleasure to have you on the Sun
the comfortable sofas we have here
plenty space by the way feel free to
stretch as you would an airplane just
like this we've talked about far cry
yeah um so yeah I've got a bunch of
questions to you about far cry for your
Tamil the other day and really put a lot
of people away like I think what a lot
of people myself could enjoy them at far
cry 3 was this this playground but you
kind of made for people that mess around
it I mean yeah there was a story but but
then you could also you know punch
Tigers and whatever you wanted to do so
that was well not Tigers with clients
but whatever it was great so far cry 4
yeah is it more of the same are we are
you going even more down that playground
great I think I want to see we're
building far cry 4 we had one mission
right we think about two years ago we're
finishing Far Cry 3 and we're like where
do we want to go next
and we started to talk about all the
things we wanted to do and there were
some ideas thrown out of all let's just
stay on the island let's just keep Jason
let's just keep to all the characters
that we have and everybody's like
absolutely do not do that go to a new
location I want to be able to I want to
be able to hunt new animals I want to be
able to see all kinds of different
biomes I want to be able to have
completely different experiences and I
want to do it in co-op so our game
director was like ok look here's what I
want I have one vision for this I want
to be able to get on top of an elephant
and I want to be able to smash through
the walls of an outpost so it's actually
a fortress that can also fight back and
I want to do that in co-op so if there's
two elephants you can do that too
and we're like okay let's do that okay
now I have a bunch of questions but it's
one question I'm hoping you might be
able to confer go maybe exclusively for
four games but Mary okay that's pretty
fresh on you so looking at this setting
I just thought there's one animal that
must be in this game I know what
question this is gonna be can I hunt a
Snow Leopard
a Snow Leopard other snow leopards in
your game can I hunt Snow Leopard apart
I know what there's a bunch of animals
but honestly there's one in particular
that I'm super afraid of that's gonna
sound a little weird okay when you're
walking through the snow and you're
doing all this stuff and you got the
elephant one of the meanest animals and
the in the game is the honey badger oh
you've got honey badger we have a smart
and they're mean okay those snow
leopards you know
we'll see you see we'll see if you could
put one in for me that'd be great zoos
are like super endangered so you can
never hunt one in real life or probably
ever see one in real life
so in Far Cry 4 that'd be super great
but your honey badgers yeah we've got
elephants elephants we gather different
animals that are out there
I mean wanted to be able to do is create
this living world we're gonna take you
up to twelve thirteen fourteen thousand
feet won't you be able to cliff dive off
of that and go into the wingsuit we want
you to see the living world see all the
systems that are there and we'll have
experiences that you haven't had
previously in far cry I mean the idea of
verticality if you decide you want to
get up in the morning you want to have a
digital vacation by effectively grabbing
some carabiner gear and climbing up to
the top and you and a buddy just going
wingsuit for the day by far cry for
awesome so you said you and your buddy
let's talk let's talk cause all right
let's do it you guys dropped a bit of a
coop bombshell that's where this Sony
press comes we do it like hey you know
you've got one copy [ __ ] for your
buddy visit who can still play yeah how
does that work tell me more the way we
built it was we wanted to make sure that
we protect the autonomy of a
single-player experience so if you're a
single-player person and you just want
to be able to do that and have fun you
can do that but at any given time you're
gonna be able to invite your buddy and
to be able to play in the open world and
from the standpoint of if you're on the
PSN network we want to make sure that if
you don't have the game you have a
chance to be able to go out and try it
the nuts and bolts of exactly how it's
gonna work I won't bore you with the
details but what I'll tell you is we're
gonna be charming and we're gonna be
generous we want you to be able to
basically download the game jump into
your buddy's game play is Perth play for
a couple hours run around experience the
entire to the open world take over some
outposts take over some fortress
understand what it's like to be able to
wingsuit to be able to climb on top of
the elephants to be able to get a whole
bunch of new vehicles and weapons and
effectively play the game so you're
gonna get like a big taste you get a
good idea is that you get a very I so
the co-op in general though so let's
pretend we both bought the game we're
playing it yeah
is it the whole world the whole world of
transport is go up yeah yeah absolutely
what we want to be able to do is say
look if you love the single-player
experience and if you wanted to go and
take over that outpost or climb that
Tower or climb that mountain if you're
playing in co-op you're gonna want to be
able to do that too
don't want to make it so that you can't
do stuff you want to make it you can
play with the toy you can enjoy the
anecdote Factory so we went we make it
if you see it you can go there and with
your friend you can have a blast amazing
so you mentioned that you mentioned the
verticality mentioned the mountains that
you can scale and wingsuit off but I'm
understand there's also like a variety
of environment so we've got like yeah
is it jungle as well like this and so
that was the thing as we grow from sort
of Far Cry 3 we'll make sure that you're
able to see different experiences you're
able to see snow you're gonna be able to
climb up and where it's super cold
you're gonna be able to fly around and
understand that you're in different
biomes you're gonna meet different
cultures we want to give you the full
varied experience all the barriers of
sort of different areas that you can
play at the foot of the Himalayas
fantastic so and we're just watching
through some of that is the brilliant
explosive elephant moment from the
gameplay the press comes the other day
so am
you've got fortresses right these are
right boots that's right so is that same
mechanic back there's gonna be a posts
around the map that yeah these these
fortresses are outposts on steroids okay
okay so if you know if you know what
outposts from Far Cry 3 you know how it
works you kind of walk up to it you
understand that you got a 360-degree
approach you know how you want to attack
it these are a little bit different one
they're bigger they're stocked maybe
there's elephants inside it you don't
know they've got huge walls on them you
know what they're gonna be tough to get
into some of them are manned by mortars
and if you get too close you're gonna
get pounded so it's super important that
you figure out that way that 360-degree
approach and maybe call a buddy
you heard AJ say that perk buddy I'm
gonna need some help jump in and help me
out here and they're able to attack it
by flying it over top one person maybe
is on an elephant another person's
flying in on a wingsuit maybe there are
in a gyrocopter I mean it's about choice
okay fantastic
well speaking a bit about the wildlife
we got the you'd be able to ride elf as
he said like so you can climb on the
back without absolutely ride it into
that absolutely if we do one thing right
we want to be able to weaponize an
animal and have it be a living tank that
is a very specific key to a very tough
lock what an elephant is going to be
absolutely badass what about that poor
elephant when he dies though like how do
you not die in that exploding car he's
put it's our elephants but those things
are tough yeah when you're on top of
them and you got a bunch of jeeps coming
at you with a 50 Cal the best weapon in
the game and my
opinion is the elephant did you want
elephant riding in real life to China
you know to that we did one better what
we did is we knew that we had to make to
to create a compelling universe to make
sure that we understood what it was like
we sent a bunch of the devs over there
and what was really interesting is that
we didn't get it right at the first time
we sent some guys over they started to
have an experience that came back and
they looked at our game world and they
went you know what guys we got the scale
wrong we got the feeling wrong I need to
be able to make it so that I can smell
this game that's we want it's got to be
as real as possible and we realized we
didn't have it right so we had to fix
some stuff we had to change the scale we
added in a couple of extra elements and
different features and animals and I
think we got it right now
Cohn re in Far Cry 3 for me that was
kind of two stars of the show there was
the world I know there was Vice yes all
right
he was amazing now you got on you crazy
bad guy this time around taking min tell
us about pagan there okay well here's
the thing we want to make sure that it's
not always the exact same brand of
insanity right and what we do is we
chase the performance different brands
of insanity you know that when you met
everybody met boss boss was like that
guy on the on the playground who
basically comes up to you and says okay
give me your money right everybody has
that experience when they're a kid where
there's a bully boss was absolutely the
quintessential bully hagan min is
different Megan min is that friend that
you have that you know is bad for you
he's that guy that comes up to you after
school after work whatever else and goes
hey dude let's go steal a car and you're
like this is a bad I talk about I've
never done that what do you seen you in
I'm just saying everybody has one of
those friends and they know the truth if
they don't have that friend you are that
friend yeah exactly exactly you know the
fact is is that if you got a buddy like
that it's super hard to they're probably
the most fun to hang out with but the
reality is they're not good for it
you're gonna end up either dead or in
jail
so pagan min is that guy he's got charm
but he's also chilling he's pretty
ruthless as we see in this scene here if
that's a so is this their the intro to
the game baby this is this is the first
five minutes of the game from the
standpoint of when you join the game
what we wanted you to do is experience
the idea of smuggling yourself into a
closed country so Ajay's literally got a
fake passport he's inside this bus and
he's trying to smuggle himself in what
he doesn't realize is that peg him in
knows about him he knows
and he's he's on his way to meet him and
what's really spooky about pegida man is
that when he meets you for the first
time what you're probably expecting it's
okay this guy's gonna take out a hammer
and he's gonna kill me the reality is is
that he looks at you and he goes it's
you this is amazing you're here buddy
let's do this he gives you a great big
hug he says we are gonna go out and
cause some serious trouble so when
you're so he's like the leader of this
country so it's easy your adversary then
come back to that friend you don't know
if this guy's good for you or bad for
you he's gonna kill you with kindness
reality is what's really scary about
pagan man is that he's been leading this
country for 20 years his face is on the
money there is nothing that he can't do
right nobody said no to this guy for 20
years
so what's gonna happen is you're gonna
walk into him you're gonna meet him and
he's gonna say let's go do some stuff
and you're gonna go maybe that's not a
good idea and you watch his face change
as he goes are you telling me no is that
what you're doing okay
it's it's spooky what sir were you guys
ever a bit worried you know like
bringing back you know another kind of
bad guy who's like totally out there
it's really crazy but you're worried
that people might be like guys you've
done this trick already you've had Vice
is just vies - like it's hard I mean
honestly we wanted to know if we could
capture lightning in a bottle again you
think about you think about how great
the performance Michael mando gave think
about how great loss was and everybody
loved him we put the character out there
people saw the first blush of sort of
seeing him in the suit and then seeing
the hair and everybody sort of judge a
book by its cover and then you meet up
for the first time I think they're so
different that we went through the
process of saying if we put these two
guys in a Cell and we locked the door
and we left them for 24 hours who would
come out and the answer is not clear I
think the scariest answer would be they
both come out in their buddies so for me
pagan min we've done a pretty good job
of making sure that this guy is
different and unique and it's about a
brutal is absolutely so let's Sam let's
talk a little bit about some of the
weaponry because we suite got weak we
got you guys showed off a ton of new
toys and weaponry and in the demo there
so what else well the types of things
can we be expecting to get our hands on
I don't like death I think honestly when
you think about the fact that you got
you know for Christ's famous first
weapons I personally like the snipe I
like the long draw distance is a far cry
yeah and you think about the fact that
we know we we have systemic flame and we
want to be able to make sure that's part
of what it is that you're playing and
how you're playing we also want to give
you new vehicles like for the first time
in Far Cry you're gonna be ideal you're
gonna be able to fly so you're gonna be
able to basically climb inside the
gyrocopter and it's a co-op also and
you're allowed to be up to people in it
you're gonna be able to fly up to those
peaks go anywhere that you want you're
gonna be able to do death from above an
attack and then from the standpoint of
you know being asked a question of
what's the best weapon in the game
honestly when you climb on top of an
elephant and you realize that you can
steer the elephant and you realize that
it can Ram it's incredibly powerful it's
a living tank right and so you get on
top of this thing and it's a fantastic
weapon unto itself so I think the game
is chock-full of stuff that you can do
and it's very different from Far Cry 3
but very different from Far Cry 3 all
right you tell me over that I'm always
it different I think what makes it
different is that every feeling that you
have when you're in there and you think
about all the different weapons that you
got you think you got all the different
animals butts just the space right
adding the amount of verticality that we
have and the idea that on Front Cry 3 we
gave you the wingsuit you think that we
want to do is we want to learn from some
of the things that we've seen we want to
listen to the forums we want to listen
to some of the people were asking we
gave you the wingsuit halfway through
the game and by that time maybe we
didn't give you the the best opportunity
to use it all the place but now you got
12,000 13,000 14,000 feet
you got to wing suits you guys want to
go and fly tuning saying you got a
wingsuit for you you got a wingsuit for
your buddy you want to be able to fly
through and do it in tandem and attack
an outpost do it you want to be able to
fly into that outpost and it's now a
fortress and it can attack back maybe
there's animals that you haven't seen
before in there what happens when the
door is open and elephants come pouring
out that's that's a scary thought that's
a sickness it's a good place to think to
end thank you so much dad we'll really
appreciate you coming out you're great
to chat far cry 4 X I'll enjoy the rest
of your III what's where you off to now
honestly I don't even know yeah I fall
until I go wherever they tell me
brilliant fantastic well guys don't you
guys go anywhere because we're gonna be
back on the stage in just a few minutes
but in the meantime we're gonna go for
floor reports and I think over at the
Sony booth so let's check that out